revenant sur cet incendie dans un chenil
qui a provoqué samedi la mort de 18
chiens à saint lazare en montérégie est
et vador il ya du nouveau dans ce
tragique accident sont peu dire incendie
propriétaire du chenil qui a décidé de
parler du chili a décidé de parler à nos
collègues de civils si aujourd'hui à
saint lazare il s'appelle nick glisse ci
fais ça depuis des années garder des
chiens en fait si vous partez en
vacances vous pouvez lui confiez votre
chien et lui le garder dans saint dans
une bâtisse qu'il avait emménagé
aménageant chenil juste à côté de là où
ils habitent et monsieur evolis lui il
nous dit que il était lors de l'
incendie n'était allé visiter un proche
qui était malade et qu'il ne se trouvait
pas chez lui ni près du chenil donc
c'est les pompiers qui l'ont averti de
l'accident et que il flessel et chiens
sans supervision parce que la bâtisse
était justement aménagé pour avec des
cages pour pouvoir laisser les chiens
c'est ce qui nous dit mais par contre il
ya plusieurs propriétaires qui ne sont
pas d'avis avec les propriétaires de
chiens qui sont morts asphyxiés lors de
cet incendie et il menace il ya au moins
quatre d'entre eux qui menace de
poursuivre monsieur hugo les six ils
n'obtiennent pas les réponses à leurs
questions je vous laisse écouter
monsieur évoluent il est extrêmement ému
-déjà- à les voir en famille qui est ici
ils m'ont arraché
j'étais dans sa cuisine on s'est parlé
pour cette coupe d'or le matin m'a même
envoyé un courriel ce matin pour mon
frère courage pile sport puits d'amour
mais dans quatre militaires qui était
muet mais quand même on pense que les
règles pourraient être resserrée pour ce
genre de chez nous les règles vont être
resserrées à partir du 7 mars 2014 pour
être précis en fait le mapaq au québec
ils ont des le ministère a décidé de
demander à obliger les propriétaires de
chenil comme ses ergots lisa demander un
permis pour pouvoir ou exploiter ce
genre de chenil si vous avez par exemple
qu'un chien et plus à partir du 7 vous
allez être obligés d'avoir un permis
est ce que monsieur un gaullisme dit
c'est que lui et bien il n'avait pas de
permis parce que ce n'est pas requis
selon lui d'en avoir un et s'il propose
ce qu'il va accompagner faire de son
mieux en fait pour soutenir
un peu toutes ces dix huit familles qui
ont perdu leur animal de compagnie je
vais vous laisser l'écouté je m'en fera
tout le monde pour les aider pour faire
le rangement pour ses chiens c'est ça
que je faisais toute la semaine par
téléphone par contre elle par quoi que
ce soit à part de sun je veux aller voir
les familles et une chose aussi c'est
qu'il ya un aspect municipal à cette
réglementation là pour pouvoir garder
des chiens dans un chenil sais j'ai
appelé la ville de saint-lazare ce qu'il
me disait qu ils vont vérifier si
monsieur evolis avaient toutes les
autorisations nécessaires pour pouvoir
exploiter ce chenil sur le territoire
municipal de la ville de saint-lazare
parce qu'il ya évidemment la
réglementation provinciale mais aussi un
certain aspect municipal et comme tout
le monde est en congé à saint lazare il
ça va leur prendre un peu plus de temps
ils vont me donner des précisions
d'ici vendredi merci bada merci aux bas
à l'étranger maintenant on vient